(audience cheering)
Hi, so a few weeks ago,
we were filming the show
and I met two sisters in the audience
who said that they weren't fans of Christmas music
and it led to a conversation I was not anticipating.
Take a look.
Clap of the hands, who's not a fan of Christmas music
and finds it triggering?
(audience clap)
There you go.
May I ask why you spoke up for that 23%?
Well, we were really poor growing up,
so we never really had Christmases.
So it was kind of a hard story for us,
so it's gotten better as we've gotten older
and as we have kids now.
This is the only holiday I actually decorate now for
to try to make it better for my kids.
We're sisters, and as we were growing up,
I had to take care of my brothers and sisters a lot.
And one of our connections was you.
We always had a little bit of a tough time
between each other.
And then she was going to college in Madison
and I went out to visit her and we went
and saw "Charlie's Angels".
And that was our connection.
We just flew in last night and we'll be leaving tomorrow
because we just came to see you.
(Ross and audience clap)
Oh, that's so sweet.
Will you guys come up here really quickly?
Yeah, that's right, come on.
Ornaments were something I started collecting
when my daughters were born,
and I'm very territorial about those ornaments.
And I don't know,
maybe we can like start collecting some ornaments
or do something together, something to hang on your trees.
Would you guys ever consider coming back here
and doing something else for the show
in honor of Christmas together?
(audience cheer and clap)
Hello, hello!
Oh please, don't bother.
Don't even worry about it.
I'm so excited to be doing this with you.
And I just love that when you try to make something possible
or you think maybe something good
could come out of something and then it does,
it's so hopeful.
And we were just sitting at the news desk
with Brooke Shields, and I asked you that question
and you just came out with your truth.
Do you think that that was a relief to you
and anyone else who might have heard your story?
Well honestly, it all just came to me.
I'm not really a sharer.
Yeah, she is not.
I don't normally cry.
Yeah, she doesn't.
I don't know what it is about this venue,
but you're sharing and crying every time we're together,
which I love it.
I said it, I honestly feel like there was a connection
with you where I could honestly feel open
and honest to you.
Yes.
Good, oh, I'm so glad.
I thought when we met after I heard your story
and then at the end of the show, invited you up on the stage
and just said, "Okay, we have a connection with ornaments."
And I just thought let's have it wrapped up in an ornament,
but this is our chance to create new memories, new feelings,
and the Christmas we start now and looking forward.
How do you feel about that?
Sounds good to me, yes
'Cause I'm about to change Christmas for you.
(audience cheer and clap)
Just you.
If we have a connection,
maybe we have our own little Christmas miracle between us.
You manifested coming here.
I zeroed in on you.
None of this happened by accident.
No, it was meant to be.
So from here on out,
can we be Christmas friends
and make each other an ornament every year
and build new nontraditional traditions?
Yes, anything you want.
Anything, we love you.
Okay, great, perfect.
(audience cheer and clap)
I'm gonna start with these two.
I'll start with those two.
There's a little something inside.
Okay.
No.
Yes, thank you.
Yes, just a little something something.
(audience cheer and clap)
Obviously, spend it however you want,
just a little Christmas treat
to kind of get yourself some Merry Christmas presents.
And I'm very grateful to Arhaus
who helped us make this possible
because obviously there's each a $2,500 gift certificate
inside those beautiful ornaments.
(audience cheer and clap)
I know, thank you Arhaus so much!
No, thank you.
Okay, so.
(audience cheer and clap)
Thank you, this is so nice.
They're similar, but a little different.
And that'll be the first ever tradition we start.
Thank you Drew.
Thank you, thank you.
(audience cheer and clap)
Thank you Drew.
Yeah, it's gorgeous.
I love it.
I'm really happy I met you.
We're happy to meet you.
And I'm glad we found each other.
Well, Nikoll and Jessica, thank you so much.
And maybe we can make a date for next Christmas too?
Yeah, why not,
Definitely.
I never imagined, to just be around you.
You are everything that anybody could think of
as far as greatness and kindness and light.
I mean, I always remember that day
when I saw a pop-up on Instagram, or YouTube
and it was like, "Tickets to 'Drew Barrymore show'"
And I turned and I looked at my husband and I said,
and I don't do this, I said,
"I'm going to New York and I'm gonna meet Drew Barrymore."
And I texted my sister and I was like, "Would you go?"
And boom, here we are.
And I mean, never did I imagine, never did I ever.
(audience cheer and clap)
Thank you Nikoll and Jessica.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)